hello everybody and welcome to part 7 of
let's play a number of the Black Plague
we just left off i trapped a monster in
room here this room here oh oh oh what
oh I will
oh come on I want to face him I'm tough
tougher than you oh shut up
oh man okay I did this uh oh yeah yeah I
did I put all the cards in it went
flashy flashy boop boop something must
have happened
let's see what happened what really what
changed I have no idea this computer on
ah all year
let's see current operations ooh uh huh
Oh I was there I think
yeah totally there especially tomb
I don't know about that Oh to nut X Z no
research up aliens I wonder what it was
uh aliens all right what a cave I was
there
let's see oh no oh no oh that's where oh
that's where I got infected as
constantly entertaining oh my god
there's no recollection at most I'm
trying to talk here shut up go places
man somewhat of a predicament what's
this
saboteur Oh some reason he conjures in
my mind the color Billy it's Billy dark
and or ID I don't know
but munch but monk nope how about door
ID your face oh I know I totally know
library nope I screw you screw you and
your face Oh
no yeah no door Oh 306 100 so I could
have remembered that shut up that's it
one boom
oh so awesome Oh mega awesome now right
uh-huh
come on I'm ready off so raise that
monster still here not for long so I get
done with them or is that this Oh got
batteries oh I hate this flashlights the
worst oh it's got like no batteries I
swear all right yeah all yeah all the
infirmary
on now this is where the sick people
don't go so who knows who's in here
all right bring it on a bed ooh come on
oh yeah
what's this uh-huh I no time for that
who a bathroom no sewer all right what
do we got oh yeah flare I need you I
really need to start using the flares
that's probably why they give me I got
like four and I've never used one I'll
use one on accident let's see alright I
got here oh yeah oh this looks great
oh yeah thank you oh come on I'm gonna
you shut up
no oh yeah oh that's how I solve all my
problems this gay somnus this K wasn't
that something in amnesia I don't know
cryostasis you saw gay Pollak I uh-huh
and patients infected
okay there's lots of monsters in the
cryo chamber okay
access
probability of rehearsing death um uh
whatever all right whatever
I'll boring up save and computer oh yeah
hey baby dude it was the last time I
look so great baby you're just at a
higher resolution oh shut up damn it
note to self never insult your last hope
of survive yeah too late
I'm not coming to save you advice those
creepy artifacts uh-huh we don't know
how they were shut up or even well I do
I suppose we well I saw someone get too
close to one uh-huh you probably don't
want to know I'm sure you'll be fine
yeah probably
I've touched every single one if you
happen to find yourself in my neck of
the woods I'm kind of trap oh yeah
it's no big deal really just throwing it
out there well where are you
that's hardly completely harmless go on
just like wrapping yourself up in a warm
blanket uh oh this case ominous
following in Jacobs her door close to
such a rate that it appears that oh yeah
ah I can appear dead oh just so great oh
yeah oh let me just let me fill myself
right up oh yeah go oh shut up you're
not confident build some confidence
god damn it John Bera Singh me oh okay
throw something at it oh but don't throw
it cushion it Oh chair come on yo you
bust pieces oh but uh age for
alliteration beard for bohemian she is
for Carson
signature carcinogen carcinogenic oh
[ __ ] so stupid take no space in my new
hot doctor let me do a little spring
cleaning
hush shut up hey you didn't need the
periodic Oh fu fu man I hate you are you
just gonna start deleting my memories ah
man is not cool man
not cool door to krile
okay I need um non-human sample am I not
humid already ah ah awful awful awful
awful let me go save that lady yeah
alright let's see where's am at listen
wait what oh yeah nevermind huh just me
been stupid oh right I went to three
storage no I went to the armory he said
it was in storage I gotta go storage
okay go this this way uh-huh uh-huh ah
here making progress
I think this games actually designed
better so then like even a genius like
me doesn't get lost do it stupid puzzles
ignore are those times you before that I
got lost
whatever Oh who's there oh oh is it you
lady I'm Emma Belle I'm here to save you
alright ah here's time Oh
storage always good who's great in the
amnesia games it's great in overture I'm
sure it'll be fine here huh but this oh
don't look so bad oh alright
let's see
a crate here a leak rate stacking skill
up Oh nope okay I think I can make it
from there give me yeah yeah okay point
get over there
all right here we go Oh Lee oh come on
uh uh hit you
Oh where'd my mouse go oh no I come on
oh you son of a [ __ ]
I hate Oh what up but ah god damn it
oh no no aah God mother aah
all right that worked ok I'm fine behind
uh ah stops spinning why are you
spinning why I don't know physics is
weird in this game so weird all right I
need more so I'll take the eyeball
nothing of interest I'll show you it's
all sorts of things of interest
I see like that and one of these like
all oh so gently okay all right oh come
on
I oh I'm gonna a son of a mother oh all
right
huh oh don't embarrass me just after I
said Oh boots goop designer not be stuck
on by idiots like me oh okay that's good
huh
stops hey OH
if I picked up something in real life it
would not do that
all right fine fine I'm gonna stick it
oh so high that it doesn't even make
sense get flat I hate you I hate you oh
you son of a-- our mother
oh now you get flat uh yes no all right
gently so they doesn't hit anything else
and this ideal crazy boring
oh come on boy ah
I made it oh yes oh yeah I'm so pleased
great context of this monkey it
certainly wasn't oh shut up if I can
just there you see it's like what twin
clay
Martha he'll hate to interrupt you while
you're showing off your logical problems
oh let me put it more simply
you see uh-huh I want you to see Oh
f-you
why did you make me see up what box what
if you move around will it you can't
look up the magician sleeve oh okay I'm
holding still oh I hate you so much
what well was it what the matter with
what does it matter ah I'm so mad at
this guy
I hate him so much all right I gotta cut
it here so I will pause it thank you so
much for watching and I will see you in
part 8 of let's play penumbra the Black
Plague bye bye